really fast I want to tell you about our
sponsor bespoke post the subscription
club for men every month you get a
brand-new box filled with high quality
products to spice up your everyday life
in my box I got a set of really high
quality beer glasses from Germany as
well as a beer growler made of amber
glass designed to prevent sunlight from
spoiling your beer in another box I got
these really great handmade sunglasses
that I'm wearing every month you get
totally new unique gear worth more than
what you're paying no commitments
customize your box every month send
stuff back if you don't like it click
the link right under this video to take
their quiz and get suggestions about
which bespoke post boxes might be best
for you okay some pretty big news in the
last 24 hours the governor of New York
Andrew Cuomo has signed a bill which
would allow the release of Donald
Trump's state tax returns from the state
of New York specifically to one or up to
three different congressional committees
now there are some people who think this
is the biggest deal in the world there
are trumpets who are saying this is
nothing and the truth is that it's
potentially a moderately big deal
remember this is not Donald Trump's
federal taxes this is as New York State
taxes Andrew Cuomo signed a bill
yesterday which would allow three
congressional committees access to
Trump's state tax returns from New York
for a quote specified and legitimate
legislative purpose so now the three
committees if they want to request
Trump's New York state tax returns on
this basis are going to have to
demonstrate what is the specific
legitimate legislative purpose for
obtaining Donald Trump's tax returns the
three committees are the House Ways and
Means Committee the Senate Finance
Committee and the Joint Committee on
taxation which includes members of both
the House and Senate so number one
there's still a very long way to go here
can they actually demonstrate a specific
and legitimate legislative purpose
number two can Donald Trump or any other
agency or department challenge this in
total like challenge the law in total or
specifically challenged a request on the
basis of that particular request not
being not demonstrating a specific and
legitimate legislative
purpose number three would the New York
state tax return if we were to see it
give us all or most of the same
information as Trump's federal tax
returns the answer to that is we
wouldn't get everything from a New York
State return that we would from a
federal tax return but we would get most
of it and I am interested in this and I
want to see Donald Trump's taxes but
this is one of those things where it's
really important for the left to manage
expectations should Donald Trump have
released his tax returns from the
beginning absolutely do we want to see
Donald Trump's tax returns at this point
in time even this late in the game
absolutely we do our Trump's tax returns
likely to reveal anything that would be
a blockbuster in terms of either
exposing criminality or affecting Donald
Trump's reelection it's not likely it's
just not likely it could expose that
Donald Trump is not as rich as he says
but his followers don't care they'll
find excuses it might expose that Donald
Trump pays very little in taxes but his
followers will say that makes him smart
what that's the benefit of being in the
Republican Party that wants taxes lower
lower lower no matter what the
consequence is that if you find a way
not to pay taxes as Donald Trump may
have successfully done for a long time
or pay very little in taxes that's not
that's seen as a feature not a bug by
the people you're trying to get to vote
for you and then lastly Richard Neil my
old congressman from Massachusetts who's
the person who has to request that the
tax returns so far has said he's not
going to request them under this new law
that he's going to I guess keep working
on getting the federal tax returns
through some other means or something
like that so this is news and I want to
see the tax returns but it's important
not to get carried away here let's keep
an eye on what matters we want to stop
Republican bills from becoming the law
we want to get Donald Trump out in 2020
we want to pick up seats in the house in
2020 we want to it's a difficult map in
the Senate for Democrats in 2020 but we
want to try to not lose seats in the
Senate as the case may be and set up the
2022 election to maybe lead to taking
over control of the Senate and we need
to by the way I keep saying this and
I've been saying it for
years we need to make sure that the
census is done and done correctly while
we continue fighting voter suppression
so that everybody who wants to vote in
2020 not only is allowed to vote but has
their vote counted which is another
layer that Republicans have been working
very very hard to destroy as a function
of democracy for many years if not more
than a decade at this point in time so
let's hopefully see the tax returns the
tax returns are not going to be the
blockbuster that maybe some believe and
much like you know we if you were
waiting around for the Moller report to
say we have video of Trump and Putin
personally colluding you were waiting
for something all along that was never
going to happen in the same way if
you're waiting for Trump's tax returns
to be such a blockbuster bombshell that
they lead to his removal or impeachment
I mean it's just not going to happen and
I would focus on things we can control